>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Jacob Nadal: Thank
you for joining us today
at the Library of Congress.
My name is Jake Nadal.
I'm the director
for preservation
here at the Library.
Every spring, libraries
across the US celebrate
Preservation Week,
and event that was started
in 2010 as a joint effort
between the Library,
the Institute of Museum
and Library Services, and
working in partnership
with professional societies
like the American
Library Association,
the American Institute
for Conservation
and then the Society
of American Archivists.
Preservation Week is
always a welcome opportunity
to share both our
technical knowledge
and our sense of purpose.
Every day, across all of
the Library's facilities,
preservation staff
reshelf materials
that were consulted
the day before.
They ensure that everything
is in its place and ready
for the next researcher.
They perform the treatments that
keep our collections usable.
And when materials are
too fragile for use
or their formats
become obsolete,
they create new versions
to ensure
that information
stays available.
Preservation staff also do the
scientific research required
to ensure that we understand the
risks that face our collections
and that we have strategies
to bring them into the future.
We do that work to make sure
that everything collected here
in the Library has a
pathway into the future.
From time to time, however,
Congress gives the Library
special direction to attend
to the preservation issues of
concern to the American people.
Because of that,
I'm especially glad
that we can showcase the
Veterans History Project today.
We have 167 million items in
the collection at last count,
and we add thousands
more each day.
So when I say that my staff
of 180 is one in a million,
I mean it both from the heart
and from the calculator.
Working on the Veterans History
Project is a good reminder
that preservation and Library
collection-building are not just
numbers games.
It's not just one of us
and a million more
things to take care of.
Those treatment hours,
the inventory records,
all of the work to building a
collection adds up to something
that matters to people, both
the individuals and communities.
During events like Preservation
Week, and as I speak
with colleagues across the
country, I'm always inspired
to see how libraries,
archives, historical societies
and other collecting
institutions engage with people
in their communities to bring
the past into the present.
I think the Veterans History
Project is a great example
of this.
So now I will hand the stage
over to Karen Lloyd,
director of the VHP.
Karen.
[ Applause ]
>> Karen Lloyd: Good afternoon.
He's taller than me.
Thank you for choosing
to be here today.
I'm Karen Lloyd.
I'm a retired Army aviation
colonel and the director
of the Veterans History Project.
First, I'd like to give a shout
out to Jake and his whole team
for asking the Veterans
History Project to be part
of this amazing event.
One of our major challenges
is convincing veterans
and their loved ones to part
with some of those unique
and original items that
illuminate their narrative.
I know from firsthand experience
how hard it is to part
with these treasures,
but I have come
to understand the importance
of ensuring these artifacts are
available for future generations
and how the Library's
preservation directorate
under Jake's leadership
makes that possible.
As a veteran, as the widow of a
veteran, the child and sibling
of veterans, the
Veterans History Project,
to me, is more than a job.
It's rewarding, and
it's purposeful.
I ask you, how many of you
can say, I'm living the dream
when you talk to other folks.
Today, if we're successful,
we'll pass on that
same enthusiasm
about the Veterans
History Project to you.
My hope is that you leave
today with a sense of urgency
to gather the narratives
of veterans.
VHP is your opportunity to
make a meaningful difference
for the veteran in your
life for your community.
The Veterans History
Project is one
of the Library's most
popular programs.
It is one of the largest oral
history projects in the country.
Its congressional mandate
is to collect, preserve
and make accessible the personal
accounts of American veterans
so that future generations
may hear directly
from those veterans and
better understand their
selfless service.
Oral history is a principal
conduit for folklore.
It is through oral
history that we learn
about the life experiences and
perspectives of individuals
who might not otherwise
appear in historical record.
It also provides
a rich opportunity
for human interaction.
I am grateful that Congress
understood the oral history
aspect of folklore when
it developed the Veterans
History Project.
Over the past 1 years,
we have collected
over 105,000 different
firsthand narratives,
ranging from oral histories
to diaries to letters
to photographs, even 2D artwork.
Our collection spans
from World War I
through the current conflicts.
We include every branch,
ethnicity, gender and conflict.
Our diverse and rich
collection is a start,
but with over 17 million
veterans in America today,
there's a lot of work left to
be done, and we need your help.
It would have been
impossible for our staff
to archive this much history
without the direct involvement
of volunteers from
across the country
who interview veterans
in their lives.
By using the Veterans
History Project as a tool,
you help the nation preserve
our veterans' story so that we,
together, can create a living,
lasting memorial to
military service.
Decades, even hundreds of years
from now, people won't have
to wonder what happened
during the wars
and conflicts represented by the
veterans who were interviewed.
They will be able to hear
it directly from those
who were there, from the
pointy end of the spear
to those rear echelons.
Our veterans will tell
you, e need the whole story
to fully understand the
complete experience.
The Veterans History Project
history project was created
with the purpose to
collect, preserve
and make accessible the memories
of our nation's veterans
so that we can hear
directly from them
and capture what they
saw, felt and heard,
the human experience
of military service.
Collect, reach out to the
veterans in your lives
and communities and listen,
really listen, to their stories
and donate them to the
Library of Congress.
Why you ask?
To ensure we don't lose those
voices and those stories.
Today, you'll hear from Rachel
Telford, the VHP archivist
and the preservation directorate
team that supports VHP
about the techniques and
procedures available to them
to preserve these
original artifacts
so they remain accessible
for future generations.
Rachel.
[ Applause ]
>> Rachel Telford: All right.
So, before the conservators
get into the details
of how they preserve individual
items in our collections,
I just wanted to
give some background
on a few collections
they'll be talking about just
to provide some context
and give you a sense
of exactly what it is we're
preserving and the stories
that are captured
in these items.
I'm just going to
highlight three.
The first is the collection
of Albert John Carpenter.
This is the only
photo we have of him.
He is in the back row,
second from the right.
And he served in the Army
with the 142nd infantry
regiment during World War I.
He was in France in the
trenches during the final days
of the war, so he experienced
bombings and gas attacks
and all the worst that
World War I had to offer.
And he, fortunately
for us, kept a diary.
So we know a little bit
about his experience.
His entries were fairly
brief to the point,
but they contain quite vivid
descriptions of his experiences.
On October 11, 1918, he wrote,
142nd casualties still
enlarging and very weak.
Only two good meals
since on front.
Twelve a.m. a gas
shell came over.
Did not get my gas
mask on quick enough.
Sent to field hospital,
taken about 20 pills
and sent back to the lines.
So, he conveys quite a lot
just in a few short lines.
These are a couple
pages from his diary.
The diary itself
came to us unbound.
It's just loose pages,
and as you can see,
there's a little bit of water
damage there that happened
at some point before
we received it.
And in a few minutes, our
conservators will talk
about some of the work that
they have done to help ensure
that the content of the
diary remains accessible.
But the preservation of this
item starts a little bit earlier
than that.
The veteran's family donated
the diary to us in 2002,
and they knew that
they were going
to make it accessible
to researchers.
They knew that it would
be securely housed.
But several years
after the donation,
the veteran's daughter-in-law,
Shirley Carpenter, got in touch
to let us know how
important that decision
to donate this diary really was.
She used to keep the diary
in a box in her hall closet,
along with the family Bible
and all the important documents
of that family history.
And she lives down
on the Gulf Coast,
and in 2005 Hurricanes Katrina
and Rita swept through her town,
left five feet of
standing water in her house
and destroyed everything
that was in that box.
So all those pieces
of her family history were
destroyed except for this diary,
because she had made that
decision to send it to us,
and it was safely
housed 1,000 miles away.
So Albert Carpenter's story
is available here today
because she took that first
step in preserving the diary
and donating it to the
Veterans History Project.
And the second collection
is Samuel Culotta.
He's a World War II veteran.
He was from Baltimore,
and when he was 17,
immediately after the attack
on Pearl Harbor, he had tried
to enlist in the Marine Corps.
He had flat feet, so
they wouldn't take him.
But shortly after that, he was
able to enlist in the Navy,
and he served with a
naval assault beach party.
He has quite a large collection
that includes an oral
history interview.
It also includes diaries,
memoirs, correspondence, maps,
news clippings, all
kinds of materials
that document his service.
He was a medic.
He participated in nine island
invasions in the Pacific,
so he saw close combat.
He saw terrible casualties,
and there are a number
of incredible stories that are
captured in his collection.
One of my favorites is the
story of this little boy.
His name was [inaudible] Joseph.
He lived in Enewetak in
the Marshall Islands,
and his family, his
community, was caught literally
in the middle of the war.
And he was injured by shrapnel
and brought aboard the
USS Cambria for treatment
and Sam Culotta was given
the job of taking care of him
and making sure that he got back
to his family in good health.
And he mentions this sort of
briefly in his oral history,
but through the original
material in his collection,
we can really get a
sense of the impact
that this experience had on him.
There are a number of photos.
As you can see here, the ship's
tailor made a little uniform
for him.
And you can also
see in this phot
that he's got bandages
on both of his hands.
And based on some of
these images we have,
he's there in the center,
it seems like the guys
on the ship really liked him.
Samuel Culotta certainly did.
He wrote in his diary that
he became quite fond of him,
and they were both very upset
when it was time for him
to go back to his family.
He describes, you know, quickly
leaving him with the sailors
who were taking him back
because he didn't want
to see the boy crying
as he was leaving.
And this is an experience that
definitely stuck with him,
because 60 years later he
tried to track this boy down,
and he wrote to the Embassy
of the Marshall Islands,
and despite only having
a summary of events
and a phonetic spelling
of the boy's name,
he was actually able
to find him.
It turned out this little
boy grew up to be a member
of the island council,
and apparently,
has been telling the story
of the time he got to hang
out on a US Navy ship with
all his sailor friends
for his entire life.
So that letter got into the
hands of a local politician
who immediately knew
who it was about.
So after 60 years, they
were reunited here in D.C.
So our oral history collections
are an incredible resource,
but in this case, if we just
had that veteran's oral history,
we would know a little
bit about this.
He talked about it for maybe a
minute and a half, two minutes,
but there's not a lot of detail.
And but because he donated
all this additional material,
we know a lot more about that
experience and how he felt
about it, both at the time
as well as in later years.
And so it is a much
richer story for having
that additional detail.
The final collection is that
of George Washington Pearcy.
He served in the Army and Army
Air Forces during World War II.
He shipped out to the
Philippines in early 1941,
so he was there before the
outbreak of war in the Pacific.
And during this period,
he was an incredibly
prolific letter writer.
He would write five, ten,
sometimes 15-page letters
to his parents describing his
daily life, his impressions
of the Philippines, his
plans for the future,
and he would regularly remind
them to keep all of his letters.
Keep everything he
was sending back.
He would tell them exactly
where they were supposed
to be keeping all this material.
Like every other letter, don't
forget to keep my letters.
So it was clear that he thought
his experience was important
and interesting.
He wanted to document
it, and he also,
he mentioned possibly
wanting to write a book
about his experience, so
it was clear he wanted
to share his experience
later on.
After the war began,
he was no longer able
to write these lengthy
letters, and in 1942,
he was taken prisoner by
Japanese forces and held
in several prison camps
in the Philippines.
And after he was
captured, he was only able
to send a few brief postcards
home, but he did keep a diary.
And diaries, we know,
often weren't allowed
in Japanese prison camps,
so this probably was kept
in secret, potentially
at great risk.
We do know that he was
clearly using whatever paper he
could find.
Here we see some used
labels from cans of food,
and behind that there's
part of a map.
But this wasn't entirely
used as a traditional diary.
We can see evidence
that he's trying
to keep his mind active
while he's in prison.
Here he's making a
list of things he wants
to do when he gets home.
In another section,
he's compiling a list
of personal property that
he lost when the war began,
because he plans to petition
the government for reimbursement
for all of those items.
And this is another
one of his diaries.
Here, he's repurposing
medical records that he found
at the Philippine colony
where he's being held.
And you'll hear shortly about
the physical preservation
of diaries, but the first step
in preserving these diaries
happened long before they
got here.
In 1944, Pearcy was to
be transported to Japan
on a prison ship, and so
he gave all of his papers
to a fellow prisoner who would
stay behind named Robert Auger
for safekeeping and asked him
to return the material to him
if he was able to keep it
with him when he got home.
And George Pearcy
didn't make it to Japan.
His unmarked prisoner
transport was sunk
by a US submarine in late 1944.
But Robert Auger remained
in the Philippines was
eventually liberated
by US forces.
And shortly after returning
to the US, he made good
on his promise, and he mailed
the diaries to Pearcy's parents.
And it would be several more
months before his parents found
out what had happened to him.
So naturally, after
that terrible news,
they saved everything.
And this all got passed
down through his family
to his nephews, who
eventually made the decision
to donate this material
to us here
at the Veterans History Project.
And at that time, it was the
only Pacific Theater POW diary
that we had in our
collection, so the importance
of preserving these
particular items really can't
be overstated.
We actually now have to
Pacific Theater POW diaries.
The second one belonged to
his buddy, Robert Auger.
And so our conservators
are going to tell you more
about exactly how they
preserve these items for us,
and we'll have some of
them on display afterwards.
We also have a number of items
on display in the exhibit,
Echoes of the Great War here
in the Jefferson Building.
And on May 26th, we'll be
presenting a one-man show called
An American Soldier's
Journey Home, which is based
on the World War I diary
of Irving Greenwald,
which you can see here.
But for now, I will turn
things over to our conservators
who will tell you more about
the incredible work they do
with our material.
[ Applause ]
>> Jennifer Evers: Hello.
Like Rachel said,
my name is Jennifer,
and I'm from the
Conservation Division.
We have a couple of us
here today to talk to you.
The Conservation
Division is responsible
for the physical preservation
of the Library's
special collection.
And this includes everything
from examining collection items
to assess their conditions,
created written
and photographic
documentation, treating items
that require intervention
or stabilization,
monitoring their environment
throughout the Library stacks
to make sure that we're
keeping everything
in the best possible conditions.
We prepare collection materials
for loan exhibition
and digitation.
And we prepare for and
respond to potential disasters.
In addition, we support
and promote the field
of conservation by giving
lectures, conducting
and publishing original
research,
treating conservation interns
and fellows and serving
in leadership roles in the
professional community.
The Conservation Division staff
includes book conservators,
and our lab is pictured in the
image on the left, and paper
and photograph conservators.
And their lab is in the
picture on the right.
We also have a number of
preservation specialists
and conservation technicians.
I think as conservators that
we are not only fortunate
to work here at the Library of
Congress, but that we have some
of the best jobs in the Library.
We get to interact
with a wide variety
of items in the collection.
Our work requires us to learn
more about the collections
from the curators
and archivists.
And basically, we get experience
a really unique physical,
tangible connection with
our shared material, culture
and history on a daily basis.
And although today we're
mostly going to talk to you
about conservation treatments,
I also would like to mention
that quite a bit of work
takes place up front
when an item first
comes into the lab.
Objects are first examined
to evaluate their
physical structure,
composition and condition.
And in the picture on the
left, you can see Gwenanne,
my colleague, examining a book
containing Japanese coloring
examples under a microscope.
And she is looking to assess
lead red deterioration.
In the photo on the right,
you can see someone doing
photographic, sorry,
preparing to take photographic
images to document the condition
of an item before it is treated.
We also write extensive
documentation detailing
as much information as
possible about the item,
and this includes information
such as its creator,
how it was manufactured
or created,
its present physical condition,
and all of this information
helps us
to make informed
decisions about the best way
to treat or care for an item.
And finally, we meet with
curators and archivists
to discuss treatment options
and get approval prior
to undertaking any physical
treatment of an item.
Conservators receive
highly specialized training,
either through graduate programs
or intensive apprenticeships.
We learn about the structure
of physical materials
and take extensive
coursework in chemistry.
But conservation is a mix of
art and science, so we also have
to become skilled
in craftsmanship.
We learn about the historical
construction of physical items,
because in order to fix
something, you also have
to have an inherent
understanding
of how that thing is made.
In graduate training programs
for book conservation,
we were taught to recreate
historical binding models
so we can better
understand their structures,
see weak points where the
physical materials are likely
to fail and learn how to
best fix these issues.
Conservators are both
scientists and craftsmen,
and like all craftsmen,
we love our tools.
These are just some of the tools
that conservators
frequently use.
You probably recognize
a lot of them, scissors
and brushes, exact-o knives.
But some that you might
not be as familiar with are
in the top left there's a
jar of wheat starch paste,
which is an adhesive that we
often use in conservation.
The top right is a paring knife,
which book conservators use
when working with leather.
At the bottom, there's
two sheets
of long-fiber Japanese
tissue which is often used
to repair material
because it's very strong,
transparent and flexible.
And then the kind of more
tan-colored paper is a rag pulp
paper that we actually make
inhouse in the Library.
And this can also be
used as a repair paper.
I'm one of ten special
collection conservators
in the book lab at the
Library of Congress.
We're responsible for
treating bound items
in the Library's vast
repository of collections.
Unlike a museum, we don't
only collect priceless art
like medieval manuscripts and
important works of art on paper.
Although we do have an
incredible collection
of those things.
We also have very
important collections
that encompass the entire
range of human experience.
Many of the items in Veterans
History Project collections do
not, at casual glance,
have the characteristics
of something you might
consider to be part
of a special collection.
There are no jeweled bindings
or gilded illuminations,
or if there are, I
haven't seen them.
And a lot of the items
have been created
by people whose names you
might not be familiar with.
But they connect us to our
past on an individual level,
and they allow us to experience
the world through a time
and a perspective
other than our own.
And these are some
examples of books
from the Veterans History
Project collections
that have recently been
treated in book conservation.
On the top left is a
scrapbook that belongs
to Robert Frank Auger,
and he's the veteran
that Rachel mentioned as saving
Culotta's diaries and letters.
He was an Army captain wounded
in action, and he belonged to,
or he was a Japanese
prisoner of war
for 33 months during
World War II.
And after the war, he did a
lot of work promoting the sale
of war bonds, and
this scrapbook,
which I believe was probably
made by his wife, contains a lot
of newspaper clippings about
his work selling war bonds.
The top right is a very
brittle diary written
by Joseph Sweitzer, who served
on an ammunition train
during World War I.
His diary was written on very
fragile and acidic paper,
and it was disbound and rehoused
in a newly constructed
post binding
to allow for safe handling.
And at the bottom right is
a publisher's blank book
that was used as a diary
by Willing Hearn, Jr,
another soldier during
the Great War.
There's a huge variety
of bound materials
in the Veterans History
Project's collection.
These items form an important
part of our cultural heritage,
and when they become part of
our collections, we treat them
with the same deliberate care,
precision and consideration
as we would any other
books or manuscripts
in our special collections.
So now, I'm going to talk
in a little more detail
about the conservation
of diaries written
by two different veterans.
The first, Samuel
Anthony Culotta,
served as a medical corpsman
in the US Navy during
World War II, as you heard.
He was only 18 when he
enlisted, and during his time
at the Pacific Theater, he
wrote a series of diaries
in five small notebooks.
They came into the conservation
lab in pretty poor condition
with loose pages,
broken sewing thread
and torn and crumbled edges.
And I chose this image on the
left from one of his diaries
because I think this
is a huge part
of what makes the
Veterans History collection
so compelling.
At the beginning of the
entry, Culotta notes,
"And so ends my uneventful
birthday.
I nicked my nose shaving."
Which is sort of an
everyday, mundane observation.
However, at the end of the
same page, he also writes,
"I've reached a hardened state
of mind where it concerns war.
But if I ever got to thinking
too much of what I've seen
and participated in, I
believe I'd go nuts."
This is a really sad and
profound reflection from someone
who is still too young to vote
and a reminder that Culotta,
along with many of the veterans
whose diaries are now part
of the VHP collections, was just
an ordinary young man living
through very extraordinary
circumstances.
War is brutal and personal, but
his diaries, along with those
of other veterans, help
to personify these
historical events
and provide us a
valuable link to our past.
This is another of
Culotta's diaries.
You can see in the photo on the
left it's been mended with tape.
Normally, if something
were covered in tape,
we'd probably decide
to remove it.
My colleague Gwenanne will
talk more about that in one
of her treatments, but
essentially, the adhesives
and tape can damage
the paper substrate,
making it discolored
and brittle.
However, Culotta
used medical tape,
which was likely the only
tape available to him
on the binding of this diary.
This is another part of what
makes the VHP collection
particularly unique.
Signs of use and
repair are often part
of the intrinsic
history of the item
and are carefully considered
when undertaking a
conservation treatment.
That grime on the cover
might be from a battlefield
or a foxhole rather than
just general use over time.
And tape is what Culotta had
on hand as a medical officer
to fix his diary when
it was falling apart.
Here you can see it mended.
This is the diary
after treatment.
The broken sewing was
causing the pages to fall
out of the binding,
and as a result,
some of the loose pages had
become torn and damaged.
A repair tissue was
used to mend the tears
and strengthen fragile
paper around the edges.
Creases in the pages that were
covering text were carefully
humidified and gently unfolded.
Loose pages were mended
to recreate their
original bifolios,
and the diary was resewn
as it was originally.
And you can see that this
diary isn't even a properly
bound book.
It's just a compilation of loose
pages, and it's probably all
that Culotta had
at his disposal.
You can see that
the ink has bled,
probably from changes
in humidity.
Perhaps he got caught
in a rainstorm while the diary
was tucked in his pocket.
In this case, the edges
of the pages were crumpled
with numerous tears and
creases that obscured the text.
The tears were mended, the
creases were flattened,
and it's now possible to
easily read the diary.
In addition to performing
conservation treatments,
we often create custom
housings for collection items.
After they were treated, each
of Culott'a diaries was
individually rehoused
in a custom [inaudible]
and closure to ensure
that the unbound manuscript
pages stayed together
and that the diaries are
protected during storage.
The second diary that I'll
talk about was written
by Ewing Harry Miller.
Miller served in France as a
first lieutenant in World War I.
He wrote his diary in
a blank account book
with beautifully marbled
edges and a leather spine.
At some point, the
spine leather fell off,
and the sewing thread broke,
which left the diary vulnerable
to damage during even
the most careful use.
You can see here that the front
cover has fallen completely off
of the binding.
And here's another
slide showing damage.
As you can see in the top photo,
the pages are starting to fall
out of the diary, and the sewing
is partially gone along the
spine, along with most
of the spine leather.
So the diary was disbound and
resewn, which means that all
of the pages are now
mechanically attached
to each other to form a
single, solitary text block.
This image shows the sewing
frame in our book lab.
You can see that the thread goes
into and out of the sections
and wraps around the cord sewing
supports before the next section
is sewn on.
In a lot of modern books,
the pages are just glued
together at the spine.
But in most older books, the
pages are actually sewn together
like this in a variety of ways.
I don't often get to resew an
entire text block like this,
but when I get to, it's one of
my favorite parts of treatment.
Partially because it's
just fun to sew a book,
but also because it provides
a sense of connection
to the craftsman of the past,
since bookbinders have
used these same methods
for centuries.
Here, you can see that the text
block is now completely sewn.
The spine has been lined
with cloth, and the front
and back cover boards
have been reattached.
This was done by
inserting the cloth
that lines the spine
beneath the lifted leather
on the spine edges.
The book is now essentially
back together
and functions like
a bound volume.
However, it's still
missing a leather spine.
When we bind new skins
of leather for repair,
they're usually too thick
and stiff to use as is,
which means we have to thin them
down to a more usable thickness.
This green machine pictured
in the image is called
a sharfix [phonetic],
and it has a very sharp
blade that runs parallel
to a small horizontal
metal cylinder.
As the leather is
pulled between the blade
and the rotating cylinder, a
thin strip of suede is removed
from the skin which decreases
its overall thickness.
This can also be done by hand
using a knife, like you saw
in the image of the
tools or a spoke shave.
Paring usually takes quite
a while to get an even,
thin leather that is
suitable for repair.
These are some of the finishing
tools that we have in the lab.
They are brass tools with wooden
handles that can be heated
over a stove and used
to impress gold lines
and designs in leather.
Although these tools
are probably only
about 20 years old, tools
just like this have been used
for hundreds of years.
There has not been a lot of
change to the technology.
The jar in the back
of the picture holds
scraps of gold foil.
Unfortunately, there
were just enough
of the original spine lines
left on Miller's diary to tell
where the lines had
been originally tooled.
And here you can see
the completed treatment.
The diary has been resewn
and repaired in leather.
Gold lines have been
tooled on the spine,
just as in the original.
And the book once again
functions as a proper binding.
So, these were just two
examples of bound diaries
from the Veterans
History Project
that has been treated
by book conservators.
Now, my colleague,
Gwenanne, is going to talk
about several items
that have been treated
by paper conservators at
the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Gwenanne Edwards: Hello.
I'm Gwenanne Edwards.
I'm a paper conservator
here at the Library.
And, like Jennifer, I'm
going to be focusing mainly
on conservation treatments.
So on the screen is a
small sampling of materials
from Veterans History Project
collections that Library
of Congress paper conservators
have treated in recent years.
So they include inscribed
maps, watercolor drawings
and letters with ephemeral.
The first paper conservation
treatment project that I'm going
to discuss in a little bit
more detail is a map drawn
by Gale Mattison,
first lieutenant
in the army during
the Vietnam War.
The map depicts hamlets
within Binh Thuan Province
where Mattison was stationed.
And it contains a detailed
legend identifying areas
such as schools,
locations of barbed wire
and communist-friendly enclaves.
The map is drawn on transparent
paper, which is similar
to a modern tracing paper.
So the materials in VHP's
collections pose diverse
problems to conservators.
They're mostly on poor
quality papers common
of the 20th century, made
with what limited access
to material would allow and
often to be intended to be used
and exist only temporary
during the time of conflict.
The paper on which Mattison map
was drawn had become brittle,
breaking where the object
was most often handled
around the edges.
This caused numerous
losses and tears.
There is also adhesive
residue around the edges
which can be seen at the
top in that center detail.
And in this detail from the
bottom edge, previous removal
of a tape had pulled
away the top layer
of the paper taking the
blue-colored pencil along
with it.
So after examination and
before conservation treatment,
conservators test the paper
and media, so that's any ink,
paint or other material
applied to the surface,
to ensure the methods of
repair will not cause damage
to the object.
The extremely sensitive
transparent paper
and the modern-colored
media used
in the Mattison map required
more extensive testing
than normal.
And this treatment also provided
an excellent opportunity
for a conservation intern under
the supervision of a conservator
to gain experience with the
maps-challenging materials.
So prior to treatment,
the intern tested several
possible repair papers,
adhesives and mending
techniques.
And then based on her testing,
she chose appropriate repairs
that would prevent the
media from bleeding,
wouldn't distort the
paper and were invisible
from the front of the object.
And on the right you can
see an example of one
of the tears that's
been repaired.
An adhesive from a previous tape
on the top edge has
also been reduced.
And tape and adhesive is the
most common condition issue
conservators find when
working on VHP's collections,
and they can be removed
with a variety
of techniques including heat,
and that's what was done
with the Mattison map,
an example of that kind
of treatment is in the top left.
Or with substances
applied to the surface
that soften the adhesive,
and that technique is
shown on the right.
Although time consuming,
when going well,
tape and adhesive
removal is, I think,
one of the most satisfying
conservation treatments.
So finally, the Mattison map
required filling in both paper
and cran [phonetic] losses.
The intern filled the paper
losses, such as the one shown
in the bottom left of the slide,
with a repair paper she created
to match the original.
So both that insert, as well
as the one shown on the right,
were then further toned to
visually integrate the losses.
And some of the materials
conservators use
for toning fills are
shown in the top left.
The toning materials are all
either reversible or applied
in a reversible way, as
reversibility is a main tenant
of ethical conservation
practice.
The reversibility is
important because if we decide
to remove any fills
in the future,
we can do so without
causing damage to the object.
So again, here was the map
before conservation treatment
and then after it had
been physically stabilized
and the damage made less
visually distracting.
And it can now be safely
handled by researchers
without causing further damage.
So most items from the Veterans
History Project require less
extensive conservation
treatment.
The goal of the next
two treatments was
to physically stabilize
these two diaries
of George Washington Pearcy to
prepare them for digitization.
So the diaries were an
unfound papers while Pearcy was
imprisoned in Japanese
camps in the Philippines,
as Rachel described earlier.
And I'll talk first about
the diary on the left.
So this diary was written
on the backs of forms
from Davao Prison, including
forms recording the daily
weather at the prison and
prison hospital records.
And you can see an
example of a hospital form
on the left indicating a case
of appendicitis at the camp.
And Pearcy, like most prisoners
of war in Japanese camps,
suffered from numerous health
ailments while imprisoned,
and included in this diary is a
list of his own health problems,
and you can see that on the
left, as well as a 12-page list
of property he lost as a
result of enemy bombing
in the Philippines,
which Rachel mentioned.
And one page of this 12
pages is on the right.
The list include each item's
cost, the date it was bought
and the condition when lost.
So these diary pages were
generally in fair condition
with minor tears and
breaks along the edges.
So conservation treatment
of the pages was limited
to stabilization, reinforcing
weak areas in mending tears.
However, tucked into this
diary were five documents
that had been folded too
tightly to safely open
without further conservation
treatment.
These letters needed to
be humidified to open.
Humidification is a
technique conservators use
to reduces creases and folds,
as well as to safely unroll
tightly-rolled supports.
So using a humidification
chamber,
an example of a chamber
is on the screen,
moisture is introduced
in a controlled manner
to relax the paper fibers.
And then the paper is
flattened underweight.
So humidification and flattening
revealed five letters,
one from Pearcy's sister and
the rest from his mother,
sent to Pearcy while imprisoned.
The letters span the first half
of 1943, and over the months,
show growing anxiety as his
family had hardly heard from him
since the beginning of the war.
On the backs of the letters,
Pearcy drew detailed images
such as this map of Davao
Prison as well as drawings
of other POW camps
and the Japanese ship
which transported the POWs.
And although the drawings
are incredible precise,
they are pretty difficult
to interpret,
given the translucency of the
paper and of the typewriting ink
on the front interferes
with the readability.
So with more than a little
digital manipulation following
after-treatment photography,
the drawings are
now clearly legible.
In this drawing, in particular,
shows a detailed layout
of Davao, including the main
compound, a hospital, cemetery,
and then the surrounding
landscape including the jungle
and several farming plots.
So these images digitally
enhanced
by a conservator
will become part
of the diary's permanent record.
So finally, after
humidification and flattening
of the inserted letters
and drawings and mending
of the diary pages, the metal
clasp holding the pages together
was removed prior
to digitization
as it concealed areas
of the pages.
While the clasp was separated
from the diary, it was coated
with a resin to prevent
further corrosion of the metal
and to prevent the paper
from damaging interactions.
And after digitalization, the
metal clasp was reattached,
preserving the diary
as it had been made.
A custom enclosure was then made
to safely store both the diary
and the letters inside.
So following the progression
from the top left of the slide,
the diary was placed
in a four-flap box,
and then the box closed
as in the top right,
which was then placed
in a larger four-flap
that could accommodate both
the diary and the letters,
which were larger than
the diary after treatment.
So the housing adequately
protects both the diary
and the drawings while
maintaining their proximity.
So another diary was written on
the backs of food can labels,
as Rachel showed, and
remnants of US military papers.
The contents of this
diary are harrowing.
As seen on the left, it includes
detailed accounts of prison life
and the sometimes brutal
treatment the Filipinos
and Americans endured
and memories of some
of the military campaigns
in which Pearcy participated
before being taken prisoner.
And, as Rachel mentioned, the
diary also looks to the future.
It includes a four-page
list, and the first page
of this list is on the right,
of things Pearcy wanted to do
after returning home,
all of which he never
got the chance to pursue.
So conservation treatment
of this diary was minimal.
Folds along the edges were
relaxed and flattened.
Weak creases in danger of
breaking were reinforced.
Tears were mended, and losses
bridged with repair paper.
Like the other diary, the goal
of this treatment
was not aesthetic.
Instead, stabilizing
the object for handling
and digitalization
was the focus,
and preserving the
evidence of its creation
and use was paramount.
As a conservator, not really
expecting to encounter materials
like food can labels, but again,
working with VHP's collections
gives us an opportunity to work
on some really unique materials.
Finally, I want to briefly
highlight another aspect
of conservation other than
treatment and housing.
As Jennifer and I have
noted, examination
and photo documentation play
important roles in conservation.
Albert John Carpenter's
World War I diary was brought
to the conservation lab
for stabilization prior
to being displayed
in the first rotation
of the Library's exhibition,
Echoes of the Great War.
As Rachel mentioned,
the diary was saved
from Hurricane Katrina, but
another point, at another point
in its history had
suffered from water damage,
which has caused some
of the inks to bleed.
And the first page
of the diary shown
on the left is still legible,
despite the water damage,
as only the ruled lines
on the page have bled.
However, there were numerous
other pages that were illegible
or only partially legible
where the water had
caused more ink loss.
As part of the conservation
process, the paper conservator
who treated the diary first
did a thorough examination
of the object.
And one tool conservators
commonly use
for examination is
ultraviolet radiation.
And here you can see a
conservator examining objects
with ultraviolet light,
which causes some materials
to become apparent that
can't normally be seen
in a visible light.
So when the conservator used
this examination technique
on Carpenter's diary, the text
made illegible by water damage
in visible light on the left
became legible when examined
under ultraviolet
light on the right.
So she then captured
this so that the images
with their now readable text
can provide more information
to researchers.
And Jennifer and I have
detailed just a few aspects
of conservation that helped
preserve our veterans'
history today.
I hope that you can see by
the examples that we've shown
and the knowledge and investment
that the Library's conservation
division lens preserving
VHP's collections.
And when we preserve
our veterans' history,
we are increasing
our understanding
of our entire collective
shared history.
So thank you, and
thank you especially
to our VHP colleagues.
[ Applause ]
>> Jacob Nadal: Thank
you everyone.
We have a few minutes
now to take questions,
and then I believe after the
conservators will be here
and can talk you through a
display of some of the materials
from the Veterans History
Project that we have here
and have done some
treatment work on.
>> So who decides the priority?
Is it based on the risk or
the condition or the value?
How do you decide that you
can't treat everything?
>> Jacob Nadal: I'm going
to call in a ringer.
So a number of factors.
This is all done in
consultation with a curator.
>> Rachel Telford: Yeah, there
is not a simple answer to that.
We have a long list of
items that need treatment
that is much longer
than a reservation directorate
can handle in any given year.
So we kind of find out what they
have time for, and then look
at our priorities in terms
of a variety of factors.
Sometimes the things that
come in recently are fresh
in our minds, and so, you know,
we have to go back and look
at the full list and,
you know, try to get some
of the older items
that we haven't looked
at in a little while.
But yeah, we try to
work on the older items,
but also prioritize things that
would be more easily treated
if we get to them immediately.
Things like recently
adhered tape
that will come off much more
easily if we do it now rather
than putting it on a
shelf for a few years.
But year, there are
a variety of factors
that go into prioritizing.
>> Jacob Nadal: Thank you.
One of the things
that we're conscious
of in the preservation
directorate is needing
to strike a balance of
what's critical either
because of a condition issue,
it's something that needs
to be taken care of
immediately, what's crucial
because of the Library's
current exhibition, digitation
and public service priorities,
so World War I materials
to accompany that
exhibition, get some focus.
But then also having sort
of broad based collections
care strategies to slow
down for the aggregate
collections as much as possible,
the rate of damage or decay.
So you saw a lot of boxes today
in the conservators'
presentations that ensures
that just during day-to-day
handling and storage
of the items, we're
minimizing risk.
We work very closely with
the architect at the Capital
to make sure that we're
optimizing the storage
environments for collections.
So recognizing that any day
or year we can't work
with every piece.
We try to have strategies that
embrace the whole collection.
Yes.
>> Are the photographs
we've been looking
at this afternoon part of
the conservation process,
or is it part of a larger
program to digitize the contents
of the Veterans History Project?
What's the difference with
the original and [inaudible]?
>> Jacob Nadal: Sure,
both good questions.
So one question is about the
photographs you've seen in some
of these presentations and
whether they're done simply
for conservation
purposes or to document
and make the collections
more accessible.
And then also where we draw
the line or how we balance
between preservation
and conservation.
I'll speak to the less
philosophical one first.
And that is that conservation
as a matter of good practice
and professional ethics
involves prior documentation
of the condition of materials
so that we understand the state
in which they came
to the collections,
discussion with the curatorial
staff so that we make sure
to retain any important
artifactual
or physical evidence.
The discussion, for example,
of why you keep the tape
on one thing and not another,
well that tape may
tell you something
about the material
history of that object.
And we work that out closely
with the curatorial staff
to make sure that we
agree on a treatment plan.
Some documentation is often
done during treatment,
if we need to do further
analysis or assessment.
As a treatment progresses,
occasionally, I think,
I'm looking at my conservators,
there's a surprise.
And further research
is conducted.
And then of course, we
document the after state.
That corpus of materials is
important to us as we use
that item in the future
or as we have questions
about it during research.
It can also supplement
the record of that item
and become part of a plan
to make it more accessible.
There is an overlap between
the digitization we have to do
for the technical
purpose of conservation
and broader Library
goals to make sure
that the collection
remains digitally available.
At 167 million items, we're
very careful not to say anything
about comprehensively
digitizing the collections.
But the Library is engaged
in a number of activities to,
within certain bans
of the collection,
provide as much access as
possible, and with certain types
of materials to provide
digital access.
In some cases, that
depends on user preference,
exhibition priorities,
particular interpretative areas
that the Library is working in.
But and our records may engage
with or supplement that,
especially where, as you've
seen in some of those images,
we are able through our
optical techniques to bring
to the fore aspects
of the object
that may not be clearly
visible to the human eye.
As for preservation
and conservation,
we sometimes make them at
the kind of medical metaphor
that we have a public
health responsibility,
as well as a medical or surgical
responsibility, and we think
about preservation as sort
of the stewardship goal
of the Library that we
ant to provide good,
overarching care
to the collections.
That can involve
corrective treatments
or stabilization treatments
that conservators execute.
It can involve reformatting
items,
so one preservation
strategy is to take something
from obsolescent media and
move it to a new format.
We've done this with Veterans
History Project, I think,
increasing amount as we
get 21st century materials.
The letters and diaries
and photos
of soldiers now are
created on iPhones.
They're sent as text
communications.
And that material needs
to be migrated off its
original digital carriers
and into new platforms.
We also do a great deal
in the preservation realm
for the environmental
control, emergency response.
We have a 24/7 team
that's available to respond
in case there's any emergency
that affects the
collections in the Library.
So, we think about preservation
as an all-encompassing strategy
and conservation as an important
element of the interventions
that we take with
those items over time.
Great. Thank you.
I think I'll hand it
over to our conservators.
Or Karen if you'd
like to say at last.
>> Karen Lloyd: In
conclusion, I just really want
to thank the preservation
director and Jake for all
that they do to help
us make sure
that these important veterans'
narratives remain accessible
into the future.
And also, I want to thank
you all for coming today.
Take care.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.